please be with you
welcome to the Dean show subscribe if
you haven't already I often think
seriously how I can communicate the
importance of talking about serious
issues like we talked about an ADIZ show
and I I tend to want to communicate to
the people this importance and in
different ways of just thinking of us in
life being on up on a long journey via
de train a plane and at one point this
journey is gonna end and that's the
journey of life so while we're here the
the intellectual people the sincere
people they know now that there's got to
be more to life there's got to be a true
purpose and they believe that design
indicates the designer and he's best to
tell us what this purpose is so that's
what we talked about on the Dean show
really serious issues and what we're
going to be discussing today is between
the two monotheistic religions Islam
which is the fastest growing religion
out there and more people are coming to
it each and every day because they see
that the the evidence adds up it's
logical as rational and then we have
Christianity and many people take this
mighty messenger as a God next to God so
we're gonna be in this episode looking
at the evidence that they use so we can
come to know is this something that adds
up or doesn't so we're going to be
taking the clear verses that prove that
he was indeed a messenger this is the
Islamic viewpoint the one that really
makes sense to a lot of people that's
why people come to a sign and then the
doubtful versus the ambiguous verses
that people want to use to prove that he
is God Almighty or the literal son of
God so if you're one of those that tuned
in and you really are confused about
this matter we're gonna look to
unconfuse you in this episode of the
Deen show so you continue continue on
with this very important journey here on
the D show we'll be right back this is
back here on the Dean show Salaam
alaikum peace be with you
why do you gonna said I was lucky but
got together well see him I'll just
about to call you in Ron because I was
thinking of my dear brother who you know
and I know how is he doing pretty good
is my my teacher saw differently I think
he'll be watching we can send em salams
show said American runway career on now
now I opened up the show a lot of times
we know the serious nature of this topic
and I had made an example of life
thinking about it as if you're on a
journey you're on this train and the
train want rise soonerlater is gonna and
you're gonna have to get off the train
this life will end and some people are
just into all the different
entertainment mental laziness whatever
it is all religions are the same I'm
just gonna fight then you end up making
up your own religion atheists you know
they try to deny God but internally they
really deep down believe in God but then
they also end up making up their own
superstitions and religious and why do
you say what do you say to people to
even get them to this step to thinking
and and and reflecting and were the
important so they can get to you know
examining the different religions that
are making the claim to their the truth
mashallah you have asked a very
important subject that you know how do
we bring people first is even to start
thinking about about religion or right
religion or wrong religion or no
religion the first and foremost most
important thing is see we are not here
in this world by our choice no one asked
us before bringing us here so someone
else has actually placed us here so that
someone else is the one who is running
the show for us and we need to know what
he wants from us if not the next almost
like you know we have a mobile phone if
it doesn't work what do we do we dump it
we destroy it similarly we may be
destroyed as well if we do not fulfill
the purpose of our creation so first and
foremost it's a very important thing
every person to be asked is the purpose
of life why are we here and by whom are
we here whoever has placed us here has
the right to dictate our life and
regulate it and the one who created as
the manufacturer the producer would tell
us the best way to live and lead this
life now I'm sure the the people who are
tuning in now they hopefully
they've gotten to that point yeah
they've gone through many of the
superficial things had the material
things it's not bringing joy and
happiness in one's life so now they're
like maybe on that quest there's some
confusion now the monotheism
monotheistic religions you would say the
top would you say the top three would be
or the top two is in society
Christianity so now they've looked at
all the other religions pantheism it
doesn't make sense you know Hinduism all
these other thousands of gods what not
they came to Islam and Christianity yet
okay but now we go on in the divide no
we believe that Jesus was a mighty
messenger who was sent by God calling
the people to worship God but he never
claimed to be God so people from their
upbringing many they were taught they
just go with the flow they slide it in
on church on Sundays and praise Jesus
and God and Trinity and it's all
confusing we are here to set the record
straight to click to on unclear to
things show different so let's start off
with some of the clear verses that suck
that that are clear from the Bible show
that substantiate also the the Muslim
claim that Jesus was not God sent by God
but he was indeed a servant a Messenger
of God will go through that cycle okay
first and foremost Allah so Allah says
in the Quran in surah al-e-imran so
remember 3 our number 64 audhu billahi
min ash-shaytaan-i'r rajeem Hulya al al
khattab to Allah Allah Karim intensiva
in banana obey nakum alone Buddha Allah
Allah Allah Subhan Allah says said to
the people of the book especially
referring to the Jews and the Christians
come to common terms as between us in
you and the first common term that allah
subhanaw taala speaks about is Alana
Buddha illallah that we worship none but
the true God so this is what is the
command of Allah so Allah in the Quran
and which is further reiterated in the
concept of God in a nutshell in the
Quran which is suitable a class as they
say the touchstone of theology in the
Quran which is surah number 112 are
number one which is a who Allah who I
had say he is Allah the one and only now
when we go back to the Bible and see the
statements in the Bible made by Jesus
himself or the previous prophets or the
the general context in the Bible so let
us see some of the verses there's words
in the Bible in the altar
ermand said by Moses peace be upon him
in book of Deuteronomy chapter 6 verse 4
where he says Shama Israel ooo I don't
know Allah he know under my hood here o
Israel the Lord our God is one Lord now
amazingly the same is repeated by Jesus
peace be upon him in the New Testament
where he says in Gospel of Mark chapter
12 verse 29 Shama Israel ooo Adonai
Eloheinu Adonai HUD here o Israel the
Lord our God is one Lord now these two
verses are setting this the the tone
straight the concept is there is only
one God and if you go in the Old
Testament all the previous prophets
including Moses peace be upon him had
never even if spoken of a duel or a
triune God doesn't that mean that it was
never part of the plan to have a double
a dual or a triune God by the almighty
or the concept of Trinity ever did Moses
ever understand Trinity no it was never
day rather God said in the Old Testament
in book of Deuteronomy chapter 5 verse 7
to 9 book of Exodus chapter number 3 of
chapter number 20 were says 3 to 5 he
said that I am a jealous God and there
will never be a second god book of
isaiah chapter number 43 verse number 11
book of isaiah chapter number 45 verse
number 5 book of isaiah chapter number
46 phenomena or some benign he says that
I am the only God I am the only Savior
there is no one else besides me so God
is making it absolute clearly there is
only one God so let us see now what
Jesus peace be upon him has to say to
his people he says further to his people
after saying that there is only one God
he says in Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 19 verses 16 and 17 - the person
who comes to him and says good master he
says he replies to him and he says there
is none good except one that is God he's
not even taking the small title like
good for himself he's differentiating
himself from God he goes further and he
says if you want to enter paradise if
you want to enter into life into eternal
life keep the commandments
he's not saying you have to believe in
me as God never did he say one more
verse gospel of john chapter 5 verse 30
he makes it absolutely crystal clear
that he's never any part of divineness
he says I can of my own self do nothing
as I hear I judge and my judgment is
just the
cuz I seek not my will but the will of
the Father who has sent me so we covered
three now here o Israel the Lord thy God
is one our God your God this is his way
so he's being he's separating himself
from from the divine is on the vine yeah
so that makes sense so and then similar
the second matthew 19 16 17 matthew 19
chapter 19 verse 16 and this is in every
version of the primary version of the
way it hasn't changed yet
yeah and then the third one is the the
one where he says I can do nothing by
myself so when someone says I can do
nothing by myself at least he isn't God
at least he is in God because he's
saying I can do nothing about myself
God is someone by any definition of the
world someone who can do everything by
himself and if Jesus is not I can do
nothing by myself that really clearly
clarifies that he's claiming I'm not God
that's deep I can't do nothing except
what God Almighty gives me the
permission to do he's saying it is clear
it's there and what we have of the Bible
left we're gonna go ahead and take a
break and come back we cover 3 we'll get
some more some clearer these are pretty
clear straightforward yeah okay we'll be
right back with more hannity show don't
go anywhere
please subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we're talking
about one of the mightiest messengers
and and again I know this can be a very
sensitive topic for some people but
notice we're not ridiculing Jesus we're
not mocking him drawing funny pictures
of him like many people do we think
that's a great disrespect to this mighty
messenger and you can actually go to the
Hellfire if you deny that he was a
messenger sent by the Creator according
to Islamic teachings yes right it's an
article of faith to believe to love him
so we love him dearly
but we only say of him what he said of
himself what God said of him that he was
a servant
a Messenger of God and he never claimed
to be God that's right so we're talking
about the clear verses you mentioned 3
yep and we'll tell us someone yes know
exactly about already the other words
his Gospel of John chapter 17 verse 3
where Jesus says not this is the
remember this is the words which
resembles with the Islamic Creed as well
you know Lyla
illallah
so Jesus says in Gospel of John chapter
17 verse 3 he says and this is life
eternal that you might know thee the
only true God and Jesus Christ whom thou
has sent so what Jesus is saying is this
is the purpose he's saying that you got
to know the only true God and Jesus Dow
whom have sent which means la ilaha
illaallah as mohammed rasoolallah he's
saying a Issa Rasool Allah he's saying
there is a you have to know the true God
and you got to know me the prophet of
God has been sent by God this again
differentiating himself from the
divinity of God he's not saying the
purpose of your life is to know me the
only true God now he's saying your
purpose of life is to know him the only
true God and Jesus Christ the one whom
have been sent by God so this is another
clear words where Jesus actually
separates himself from the divinity of
God so if you're sending someone away
you're not the same not the same person
and all there's not possible and the
same language is using the Bible in the
Old Testament for previous prophets
Moses sent by God David sent by God
Jesus similarly sent by God I think
people if they don't want to just be
stuck on cultural norms or their
family's traditions following their
ancestors their grandfathers blindly
this makes sense true this makes it and
most people when you ask them do you
believe if Jesus was God or sent by God
they'll instinctive but he was sent by
God but then when they look back oh
that's not the teachings of my pastor at
church and they'll go back to what you
know they were brought up blindly
believing let's go and go ahead we'll go
further oh there's one more interesting
verse Gospel of Matthew chapter 26 verse
39 where it mentions that he walked
further there is Jesus and he fall on
his face and prayed to God now see this
falling on the face is the character of
a servant which was done by all the
previous prophets so Jesus takes the
same position he fell on his face and he
prayed to God unless he is a servant of
God he wouldn't do that
moreover in the Bible in the King James
Version and other versions artistry as
well Jesus is mentioned in the book of
Acts chapter 3 verse 20 and 26 as
servant Jesus so the word servant and
son in the Greek is synonyms to each
other so every single place in the Bible
you see son go back to the book of Acts
chapter 3 verse 26 the Greek
use their which is translated as servant
is the same Greek word so what happens
is servant and son a son is just the
same synonym in the Bible which means
Jesus is servant of God and servant of
God is never gone now isn't it that also
he's referred to as the son of man what
is it when you say son of man like what
80 times yeah exactly you know in the
Bible if you go to it initially Jesus
was referred eighty-three times as only
Son of Man and then he is referred as
son of God so all of this really adds up
a lot that you know if Jesus is Son of
Man and ask anyone is Jesus son of man
the whole world including Muslims and
Christians both agree he's not son of
man so you ask a Christian why is it
referred as son of man they say it is a
metaphor it is the title of respect
exactly
Son of Man is also a title in the Bible
it is not literal it is simply metaphor
and if you go and look at the Bible in
the further verses the Gospel of Luke
chapter 3 verse 38
God says Adam is the son of God so if
Adam is son of God what makes Jesus so
the Son of God would be also a metaphor
it's someone close to God yes the
servant the servant of God exactly
because that is the only sense that you
can extract from it because according to
the Bible there are many people who are
called as son of God David is referred
as the first Martin David is also
referred as the the begotten Son of God
according to Book of Psalms yeah so all
of this gives a very clear picture that
God is not referring to anyone as his
own son rather he's referring to them as
metaphor a title son of God meaning the
good servants of God take it easy right
now some people probably can if you want
to argue a debate some you can do that
all day and night but I think the first
thing people should do is dig dug deep
in their heart and start you know if
things start making a sense and then
over here you're resisting it because
maybe you just you know stubbornly want
to just hold on to what you've been
taught for your whole life I think you
cannot go wrong with deep down inside
asking the crater say God Almighty these
guys are you know you tuned in right now
that's a sign show ask God Almighty
directly guide me if this is the truth
here guide me to it but one key thing is
only asking God a little true exactly
and this is what exactly the teaching of
all the previous prophets did Moses ever
tell his congregation his students his
disciples to worship to someone else
other than God no he said
Oh God ask God all the previous prophets
did the same how could it suddenly
change at the time of Jesus rather Jesus
himself is falling on his face praying
to God he's put on the cross he called
cries out to God ello ello lama
sabachthani all we are saying is just
called the same God whom Jesus called
that's it but no intermediaries direct
dial up is there any other clear oh
there's one more was that I just wanted
to put forward book facts chapter 2
verse 22 jesus is Hayes's to his
disciples he says Jesus of Nazareth a
man approved of God in the midst of you
doing wonders and miracles and
fulfilling the signs now this again is a
clear text Jesus is saying Jesus a man
approved of God it's not the other way
around God made man
no it's a man approved of God that's a
gain the sign of a prophet of God Wow so
we covered how many was that so I think
total six to seven now six to seven so
we got and these are pretty
straightforward clear man this is acts
what backs to twenty to tax to verse 22
he's saying this man yes a man a man not
a god approved by God yes and not God
became man no he's saying a man approved
of God we have you know some people say
look why did he have to come like
showing off that he's God and it's like
undercover guy but you know you make
this example of if the president can you
go ahead and like yeah we'll see exactly
you know if someone's if I say I'm the
president of you know Prime Minister of
Australia you would say okay are you or
are you not
and if you see I never claimed to be
Prime Minister whereas Tony Abbott the
current Prime Minister of Australia
claims to be the Prime Minister
obviously he is the Prime Minister not
me because I don't even claim so so
similarly with Jesus Jesus is not even
claiming I'm God but God in the Bible is
claiming I am God Yahweh or Allah or
Allah and he's never saying I'm God so
how could you throw the title on him
when he has never claimed but the other
one is claiming and he himself is
worshiping to him
and this is our salvation I mean he'd
have to come up straight forward that's
what we always say there is not any
there is no clear unambiguous statement
you'd have to if he's God use it look I
and the one who I'm God believe in me my
resurrection my blood other why
you're going to hell exactly there are
two fried people claiming to be Prime
Minister's one of them does not claim
and when claims then obviously the one
who's not claiming has to be given the
benefit of doubt there that is not the
the Prime Minister because he himself is
not claiming and there is not a single
unequivocal statement in the entire
Bible where Jesus said I am God or very
said worship me that is really a very
powerful evidence to see for and we've
seen when you initially opened up you
quoted some clear verses where God
Almighty is identified I am your God
don't take any other gods besides and he
said I'm jealous God even says in the
Bible in the Old Testament book of
Isaiah chapter 45 verse 5 and book of
Deuteronomy chapter 5 verse 7 to 9 he
says I'm a jealous God meaning if you
have another one taken as God or you
worship Him that's it that's the end of
your relationship with God before we go
to break I think you also you mentioned
this one where it was it in the tryna me
or exodus where God Almighty's saying
thou shall have no other gods except the
one god this is like the Kali ma exactly
right if X or the scepter twenty or
thirty five very straight like there's
no image of God never make any image of
God God is only one there's no one
besides them it's so powerful and so
close to the ties with Islam is that you
actually realize here now that this is
LOM is only the continuation of the true
teachings of Christ and it says you
should worship no one in the heavens so
no angels okay people with no Angels
nothing on the earth and now Jesus was
even in the world even in the water and
don't make any graven image of any
likeness of anything heavens above on
the earth or beneath the earth that's it
that's if that's clear I think we did we
did justice to the clear verses from the
Bible now we're gonna come back with
some of the ambiguous verses that people
use that can be interpreted that way
this way we'll put them in their proper
context here on the D show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the video
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now what do we say
you you gotta be earnestly inside your
heart yourself asking your maker the one
who made you guide me guide me if these
guys are onto something guide me to
what's the truth that's it clear make it
simple
you can again come from a Christian
background we're not trying to disparage
on anybody not trying to intentionally
upset or hurt anybody we're just trying
to make this true very apparent and
which it is and clear we talked about
the clear verses now let's get into some
of the the other verses that people will
use to justify him he was gone yeah
let's start with one author with you I
think a very popular one is John one57
yep yep first John 5:7 yeah yes can you
go ahead see first of all allah so allah
says in the quran in surah nisa so the
number for I number 171 well at the Pulu
philosophy do not say Trinity so God is
actually clearly kind of commanding keep
away from this concept of Trinity which
is not the right one so let us see now
what the Bible says about this and this
is actually used as a proof by those
Christians who claim to be following
Jesus and Jesus and they believe that
Jesus is God so this is mentioned in the
in in the Bible in the King James
Version the First Epistle of John
chapter 5 verse 7 that just you
mentioned it reads in the heaven there
are three that bear witness the Father
the Son and the Holy Ghost and these
three are not three but one so now this
is the words that a Christian is
generally taught in the church and he
picks up this one as the proof that God
is is three-in-one now point number one
this verse of three-in-one was never
found in the Old Testament so Moses and
all the previous prophets for thousands
of years were not aware at all of the
concept of Trinity that there is a
three-in-one God and ever they never
mentioned a triune God second point this
verse has now been in the new versions
the Revised Standard Version the New
Revised Standard Version the American
Standard Version and the NIV has been
removed completely and it has been
mentioned in the profess that this is
this these verses that were removed what
corruption concoction and addition in
the Bible the ones who removed it were
thirty two great scholars of highest
eminence in the Christian world backed
by fifty two denominations so it was not
a Muslim work it was not an
anti-christian work it was the work of
the top Christian scholars now what
happens here is why did they remove the
words they said because we could not
find it in the original
text the original manuscript the
original scripture so when it is removed
there is no words which is actually
talking about three in one God there is
not a single words now which says three
in one so if the worse is removed which
was the basis by the Christian scholars
and it gives a proof that there is no
other evidence to even think right now
that there is a three in one God so when
the reverse is removed by the Christian
scholars I am you as lame people as lay
people I've got no option other than to
agree that this is not part of Bible and
this is not the belief of Christianity
now this is by what is it like 30 22
eminent scholars scholars of Christian
backed by 52 denominations so there's no
one's objecting to it everyone's agreed
this was does not belong to the Bible it
was thrown out it was thrown out okay so
let's go they have only come closer to
what Allah said in the Quran in surah
nisa surah number 4 number 171 well at
the hotel as I do not say Trinity so
there is no more verses in the Bible of
Trinity there at all now just before you
go on for the people who've heard the
the name Allah the first time Jesus and
Aramaic he would call him God by ilaha
yes video so we're talking Arabic
language yes and Jehovah would say
Jehovah would be give Li me the
everliving God yeah this is the same
creator we're talking about yes so Jay
Hawaii is a Jay Jay added is a Jay added
as in America I heard the moment I
walked in America they said don't do
jaywalking here you know you can find so
Jay is has a jaywalking in the Bible at
times for some reason let's keep it away
the actual name is Yahweh yeah now Yahoo
way if you go to the Arabic name of
Allah is yeah hi you yeah how you how
you yeah way so now you have the Arabic
yeah that yeah in Hebrew is voir yes oh
yeah yeah hi you Yahweh it's the same
word and we both of them means they ever
living so Arabic and Hebrew are sister
languages
nouns we are very similar in the you
know pronunciation hallelujah yeah Allah
exactly so if you just just roam it back
how could there be so many similarity
made up all the signs and everything
exactly everything is just matching with
every name of God in Islam it cannot be
a constant as the same God the ones yeah
let's go to another this other worse now
this is a very powerful verse every
Christian general you ask him is Jesus
God they say yes and you ask him to
prove John 1:1
John Gospel of John chapter 1 verse 1
the words Reaves
in the beginning was the word the Word
was with God and the Word was God
so now here let me read it again to just
make it to you break it down into three
parts in the beginning was the word the
second is the Word was with God and the
third is the Word was God so what the
Christian claims here is the word in the
Bible here refers to Jesus and God is
obviously the father according to the
Bible so if you not change it the word
with Jesus we will see what it sounds
like this is what the Christian claims
in the beginning was Jesus Jesus was
with God and Jesus was God so sexy
leaders as God according to the Bible
now how do we respond to this first and
foremost this statement John 1:1 is not
spoken by John is not even spoken by
Jesus John did not say this is what
Jesus said rather the history historical
facts proved that this verse was
actually a statement made by the
Phillips of Alexandria long before even
Jesus came on earth
so it was the predominant verse amongst
the Greeks those who believe in
politician so they said this is
statement it is not a statement of Jesus
point number 2 let's allow the
difference you know let a kid say for
the sake of argument it was the
statement of the Gospel of John made by
John so he said in the beginning was the
word no word in the Bible has two
meanings word is Jesus and word also
means the Word of God is the Bible they
call it the Word of God so it's not
Jesus but its word about it's a word
about in Word of God similarly if you
translate that as a Word of God there's
no problem now this is that word was
Jesus okay even if that was Jesus God
that is coming twice in this words in
the beginning was the word the Word was
with God and the Word was God
the second God is a different God - the
first God in in that verse
the first g.od is HOTAS in the greek the
second g.od god is don t us don t us
means someone from God who chose means
true God and the same God which is a
small g.od is used in the Bible by Jesus
to other people as well
in book of exodus chapter 7 verse 1
where Jesus said you all are gods and
that God has to be the small g.od
similarly here it is a small g.od a
small g.od would mean someone from God
or a prophet of God so not will it read
it again turn the small G OD into
prophet of God in the beginning was the
word the Word was with God the Word was
prophet of God makes sense it makes more
sense yes we covered - we're almost out
of time yeah last one we only got time
for one more one more ok so what we did
the other one that we can color is they
used Gospel of John chapter 3 verse 16
for God so loved the world that He gave
His only begotten Son so this I see
Jesus is begotten son now this is yes it
is there in King James Version I agree
but in the Revised Standard Version and
New International Version the word the
word the title begotten is removed from
Jesus so if begotten is removed Jesus is
Son of God
everyone is son of God according to the
Bible another book of psalms chapter 2
verse 7 it says that David is begotten
Son of God
so if David is begotten and Jesus is
begotten then what's the big difference
rather Jesus being begotten has been
removed from the Bible further so it
leaves everyone as a son of God
according to the Bible anyone who does
the work of God is son of God Adam is
son of God David is son of God Solomon
is son of God the previous prophets are
sons of God Bible even says sons and
daughters of God in book of Genesis
so just shows that Bible has a language
son of God I come to America all the
oldies the old uncles call me was him my
son does not mean I'm his literal son it
only means a metaphor or respect so God
is saying son of God which refers to a
servant of God in the Bible thank you
very much you're at a time we had a lot
more that we can cover but we gotta go
we gave people a nice little taste test
of clear versus ambiguous and it's
really clear that Jesus was sent by God
calling the people to worship the
creator and not the creation exactly yes
that's the message just a message well
as I think what you just I'll just
repeat that pray to that one God seek
help from that one God as you me guide
you to the right path beautiful thank
you so much and I think that was pretty
clear we had the clear verses that are
straightforward you don't need to be a
rocket scientist you don't need me just
Bible scholar it's straightforward here
you see there
kind of ambiguous but when they put in
their context again it's straightforward
and we would agree that Jesus indeed he
was the way the truth and the light
that's right at his time he was a
messenger sent by God in the depths of
darkness people weren't so he was
guiding people to the light what's the
light the knowledge of God the guidance
from God
this will set you on a path to get to
God to get to his paradise to his
pleasure Moses at his time he was the
way the truth and the light Muhammad is
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind a prophet that Jesus talked
about he was coming and he never also
called people to worship him nor did
Jesus know that Moses nor to Abraham
Abraham he wasn't a Jew or Christian but
he was one who submitted himself
entirely to the will of God and this is
what Jesus called you to do also and
Muhammad being the last and final
messenger these were the best of
creation they were messengers of God
teaching us how to get the pleasure of
God how to get to paradise how to avoid
a Hellfire and it starts with you
earnestly understanding that this life
will end like that plane ride that train
ride and at the end don't wait until
death comes to figure it out now is the
time and by asking the Creator to guide
you definitely he'll facilitate a way if
you're sincere subscribe if you haven't
already and continue to tune into the
Deen show we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you please subscribe
to the DCO follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below